un retrait de tous les accords passés
avec israël et les états unis
c'est la décision palestinienne annoncé
par mahmoud abbas mardi à ramallah
la raison de cette rupture la volonté de
benyamin nétanyahou d'annexer dépend de
la cisjordanie
le gouvernement palestinien estime que
le projet israélien est contraire aux
espoirs de paix dans la région
[Musique]
premièrement l'organisation de
libération de la palestine et l'état de
palestine sont absous à compter
d'aujourd'hui de tous les accords et
arrangements avec les gouvernements
américain et israélien et de tous les
engagements est basé sur ces accords et
arrangements y compris ceux relatifs à
la sécurité
deuxièmement l'autorité d'occupation
israélienne à partir d'aujourd'hui doit
assumer toutes les responsabilités et
obligations devant la communauté
internationale en tant que puissance
occupante sur le territoire de l'état
occupés de palestine avec tous ses
conséquences et répercussions basée sur
le droit international
dans le même temps le chef de la
diplomatie européenne met en garde
israël au sujet de son projet d'annexion
en rappelant notamment à l'état hébreu
ses obligations en matière de droit
international
nous demandons instamment à israël de
s'abstenir de toute décision unilatérale
qui conduirait à l'annexion de tout
territoire palestinien occupé et qui
serait en tant que tel contraire au
droit international dans le passé
mahmoud abbas avait déjà menacé de
sortir de la coopération sécuritaire
avec israël
il avait notamment évoqué la fin de
toutes les relations avec tel-aviv et
washington après la présentation du plan
de paix de donald trump censé résoudre
le conflit israélo palestinien
celui ci prévoit l'annexion des colonies
et de la vallée du jourdain qui
représente environ 30 % de la
cisjordanie
[Musique]